Can you imagine a world where 10 million
people are happier?
My my I'd go to them is very
straightforward.
I developed it because I could not
really define what happiness was,
so I took as many arbitrary points of
data where I felt happy and try to find
what was common between them.
What was common between them was the
equation of happiness and it is this
happiness is equal to or greater than
the difference between the way you see
the events of your life and your
expectation of how life should behave.
In the modern world.
We mixed two states.
One of them is happiness and the other
is fun.
Happiness is that peaceful,
contentment feeling of I like the word
as it is right now.
Fun is the modern world's replacement of
happiness.
It's,
you know when I am unable to reach that
state of happiness,
what I do is I go out on the weekend and
I go to a party and boom,
boom,
boom.
My brain stops thinking.
As long as it's stops thinking I fee,
I think I feel happy.
Happiness is not about what the world
gives you.
How much water is in this class?
Happiness is about what you think about
what the word gives you.
If you think about it properly,
you will always see that as something to
be grateful for,
something to be happy about.
I think losing it was the call to
action.
I lost my son.
All of a sudden like from,
you know,
from having a happy holiday together to
losing him was four hours and the
question that hits me at the time was
what can I do now to bring him back and
nothing I could have ever done including
locking my sense in the room and crying
for the rest of my life would bring him
back.
And to me the whole idea was I can
either choose to suffer or I can choose
to sort of accept life as harsh as it
has become and try to make it slightly
better than it is today.
So let's make it slightly better
tomorrow.
So the way I did it was very
interesting.
I,
I basically set myself a target.
I said,
wouldn't it be amazing if I can reach
out to 10 million people and just give
them that message?
It wouldn't bring it back,
but it would be likely that they'd been
today,
and that is truly,
truly,
I would say successful my life.
That has never been a moment in my life
what I felt I was having a better impact
on the Ndis.